let's talk about Hosni Mubarek Egypt's
former leader was 91 when he died a hero
to some a despot to others he was
president of Egypt for almost 30 years
but his departure was far from the end
of Egypt's problems so who was the man's
son called a modern-day Pharaoh
thirty years is a long time in power but
Hosni Mubarak's rise to power was pretty
quick he was a career military officer
who once flew Spitfires and rose through
the ranks to become commander of the Air
Force and later Deputy Minister of
Defense in 1973 Mubarak helped take back
part of the Sinai Peninsula that Egypt
had lost to Israel Mubarak the hero
became vice president two years later in
1981 he was beside President Anwar Sadat
when he was assassinated took his place
and wasted no time in asserting his
presidential authority soon as Hosni
Mubarak takes power and assumes the
presidency from the murdered Anwar Sadat
he issues an emergency law and that
emergency law essentially parents the
Egyptian police in the military the
ability to intervene with any perceived
security threat in society those
measures gave the Egyptian state
sweeping powers to arrest people curb
freedoms of speech the right to protest
and crack down on the opposition
including the Muslim Brotherhood and
those emergency laws stayed in place
throughout his presidency so there's
something to be said about the fact that
he normalized the idea of police abuse
and the establishment of emergency
military courts on the world stage
Mubarak had powerful friends the United
States in particular the Americans
needed Egypt under Mubarak the US was
able to secure a steady flow of oil from
the Middle East to world markets Juba
also helped broker talks between the
Palestinians and the Israelis when Iraq
invaded Kuwait in 1990 Egypt joined the
u.s. coalition in the Gulf War
paid off big time in Egypt at that point
is rewarded with a massive wiping of it
step he gypped had tens of billions of
dollars you're not sure with that
essentially Mubarak presented himself as
a broker of peace and stability in the
Middle East but not everyone bought it
at home dissatisfaction with his
hardline approach only grew any economic
prosperity there wasn't Egypt didn't
reach everyone and he was accused of
electoral fraud but that didn't stop
Mubarak from being reelected four times
he also survived assassination attempts
on his life so in 2011 when the Arab
Spring protests began there weren't too
many people surprised to see Hosni
Mubarak swept up in them to the death of
a street vendor in Tunisia kicked off
the protests in December 2010 and
inspired millions of people across Egypt
people from all walks of life gathered
in Tahrir Square in Cairo demanding
Mubarak stepped down things got ugly
security forces moved in but protesters
defied curfews and fought back after 18
days of protests Mubarak finally let go
Hosni Mubarak has gone but it cost the
lives of around 800 Egyptians after
Mubarak was gone the country held what
were seen as the first free and fair
elections in a close vote people elected
Mohamed Morsi from the Muslim
Brotherhood a political group that
Mubarak and once outlawed Morsi promised
to change things
[Music]
he barely lasted a year a weak economy
and resistance from Mubarak's old guard
undercut his authority and then Egypt's
military moved in Morsi was removed
thrown in jail and replaced by a
military general who remains in power
today Abdel Fattah el-sisi there's a
sense at least that the move our legacy
very much gave birth to a far far more
aggressively pressive military state
that comes to power under opted cc of
course as part of that military
establishment that exists while all this
was going on
Hosni Mubarak was behind bars - he was
facing charges of corruption abuse of
power and complicity in the killing of
hundreds of protesters during the Arab
Spring he was eventually acquitted but
during his many court appearances you
could see his health was getting worse
it was a very different image of Mubarak
not the strongman he presented himself
as while president in that time Mubarak
wasn't the only one to go a generation
of autocratic leaders were overthrown
leaving behind power vacuums and opening
up new regional rifts for example once
the Mubarak was gone cats are back to
Mohamed Morsi but Saudi Arabia the
United Arab Emirates and Bahrain
supported Egypt's military after the
coup any of the kind of civil conflicts
that we've seen whether what we're
seeing taking place in Libya Yemen Syria
and all of these different countries in
which there is this kind of
confrontation between two very distinct
types of forces one that is that gives
far more weight to the aspirations of
the majority of people versus one that
is basically the politics of old - some
Egyptians Mubarak removal brought hope
and the promise of change but for others
the end of his 30 years in power brought
chaos of
another strong man in charge Mubarak may
have gone but his hardline legacy lives
on if there's a story or a topic you
want to get your head around get in
touch with us on Twitter or Facebook and
make sure to subscribe to our YouTube
channel so you don't miss our next
episode I'll see you next week